hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning
podcasts from Monday February 8th 2016
what's going on everybody else huh Oh
m'darlin Oh m'darlin Oh m'darlin Denver
Colorado bunch of hippies and some
miners and the one Super Bowl trophy
congratulations to everybody a rockin
map killing [ __ ] cows and stinky
Greeley green Colorado man you ever want
to know you know what a bunch of
murdered cows smell like for the next
time you eat a burger I suggest you go
there on a bad smell day that's what
they call it bad smell day and then you
call up the slaughterhouse you okay
could you [ __ ] could you [ __ ] tone
it down a little you know the winds blow
it down to my house why don't you lay
off killing those [ __ ] cows you know
not saying limousine liberals out in
Hollywood out there eating their [ __ ]
tofu patties you know that [ __ ] causes
cancer don't you the [ __ ] is it tofu
sorry congratulations to the Denver
Broncos and guess what old Billy red
face he won a little bit of money
betting on the old the old man the old
man river sorry very happy for Peyton
Manning man I thought I just I didn't
want to see him go in there cuz his
[ __ ] ass kicked and I oh I know what
you guys would think today bill why did
you bet on the Broncos you didn't say
[ __ ] predict in one way or the other I
didn't have I don't have any feeling one
way or the other on the on the game I
thought what a lot of people thought I
just thought the [ __ ] Panthers were
gonna if they got up early it was going
to get ugly and I don't know but then
just everybody was saying it everybody
kept [ __ ] saying it you know do the
panties do
right everyone was just saying that the
Panthers were gonna [ __ ] destroy
they're gonna win by 17 dude it's gonna
be 17 not two buddy in the first quarter
this is what all my friends was saying
so I came up with this quick theory
because I wanted to put money on the
game you know cuz my team wasn't in it
and I wasn't really excited about it so
I figured I well if everybody's saying
the Panthers are right
how does Vegas make any money the only
way Vegas makes monies is if the Broncos
win Vegas always says the lights on even
during the day they never shut him off
they got the AC on what the [ __ ]
doors open and I don't see anybody
concerned out there right does it make
it money so I said [ __ ] I'm gonna go
against the grain I didn't even take the
points I just bet it I bet the line 100
to make one 90s through 100 bucks on it
and they've Jesus Christ
I guess that Denver Broncos defense was
was as good as they were saying I just
thought like I thought we made him look
better than they were cuz our offensive
line was [ __ ] beat up but I don't
know if you noticed the entire time when
the Broncos beat the Patriots at no
point was Tom Brady comfortable he
wasn't screaming and yelling I know
whatever the [ __ ] he yells at his
receivers you know it was supposed to be
a pattern right whenever the [ __ ] is
he yells at him he didn't do that once
his eyebrows down he looked [ __ ]
uncomfortable he felt people at his feet
the whole [ __ ] game they never felt
comfortable and you know Von Miller
would do that little [ __ ] little
little I'm going this way oh no I'm not
and the guy fell for it every [ __ ]
time on the Patriots right and I'm
thinking like Jesus Christ how much does
that do it on the Patriots stink that he
keeps falling for that and lo and behold
I watched Von Miller do it all game
against Carolina Panthers Andy I don't
know if you noticed this there's a lot
of stats how many times did you see Cam
Newton celebrating I I got as far as I
can remember zero he didn't do one of
those little first down [ __ ] point
things
eating not one kid got a ball he never
[ __ ] ripped open up his soup to show
the Superman s underneath you know you
didn't see that once Cam Newton had zero
fun in fact if I remember correctly
because I had a lot of blood wises I
probably drank as many Budweiser's his
[ __ ] Peyton Manning said he was gonna
drink by the fourth quarter the only
thing I remember Cam Newton doing was
falling down when they missed the
[ __ ] when they missed that that field
goal attempt it just wasn't their
[ __ ] day but he got mugged von Miller
kid you see just give me that [ __ ]
ball they're like [ __ ] linemen
running after like a bunch of crazed
dogs that went out of that classic NFL
quote goes that was just complete
[ __ ] domination by the Denver Broncos
defense to the point I think Peyton
Manning only had about 40 more yards
passing than I did but you know what
when it counted when it counted he got
it done so congratulations to them and I
actually I went against everything that
I said I not only I didn't take the game
I forgot to tape it like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I went to a Super Bowl party
which I always say I'm not going you
know because there's always 50 [ __ ]
people there and only like you know 12
of them give a [ __ ] about the game and
everybody else is running around and you
know all the [ __ ] [ __ ] that I [ __ ]
had a tampon up my ass above for [ __ ]
ever with those things but I actually
said you know what [ __ ] it I'm gonna go
to a party cuz you know I'm just not
into the [ __ ] game or whatever and
then I showed up and I realized I was
totally into the game and fortunately
the party I went to was great everybody
was into it
everybody was watching people were
saying stuff about the game that made
sense you know it was football fans and
the food was [ __ ] tremendous and I had
a great time I got to tell you going to
the Super Bowl party though something
that I never noticed was the just
general open hatred for Coldplay
why does everybody hate cold end why
does everybody hate that bed they're not
that bad right everybody's uh dude it's
so [ __ ] lame they get like they get
like half like Nickelback hate you know
what I mean hang on a second this
[ __ ] curtains messed up comes out I
don't know what they was singing they
were jumping around a lot I immediately
left cuz I didn't want to watch Beyonce
sass it up you know what I mean
I just I cannot the same way you know
the way she behaves on stage is the way
a lot of athletes behave after they make
a great [ __ ] play and some way that
that happened during my lifetime
it went from [ __ ] score to touchdown
just giving the ball to the ref -
absolutely
you know just [ __ ] I don't know what
you don't you start line dancing and you
just can't believe how amazing you are
right and everybody claimed he's having
so much fun no he isn't he's marketing
himself he's hard and self out right now
all right you should literally have to
put on a pair of [ __ ] stilettos when
you do it just walk the [ __ ] block
after you [ __ ] Dunkirk or score a
touchdown or whatever right so I didn't
want to watch her you know you know that
[ __ ] stupid walk that divas do but I
sort of stopped down the stage as they
cross one leg over in front
hey hey swinging their [ __ ] hips I
always just want somebody to just give
him a big [ __ ] leg sweep that's me
you know what I mean so think I want to
watch that [ __ ] so coal plague comes up
and everybody's just you know no one
wants to see him it wasn't that bad but
I can feel it you know I just what say
you know I don't understand these
[ __ ] bands that sell millions and
millions of [ __ ] records yet you
cannot find one person that will admit
that they were a fan right all you guys
right now who are nodding your heads but
uh yeah it is so [ __ ] lame scroll
through your [ __ ] phone right now go
to the Seas go down to see oh you're
gonna find you got one song admit it you
got you must have what song right what's
that one the first ten
look at me face as I walked out the
beach we'll always think you do and it
was all yellow I married a chick she had
yellow hair I didn't wear a condom I
never [ __ ] divorced and I'm still
payin chat supports does he pay child
support to her is it the other way
around that's a close one
what's the name of that broad there that
he married huh she looks [ __ ] Moody
all those good-looking chicks that do
[ __ ] yogurt there Darren [ __ ] bask
you've run in the other directions you
know and they had like those stones that
are for the Chi and they put him around
the [ __ ] house and I think they
thinks it makes him spiritual you just
got to get the [ __ ] away from you know
anybody with a yoga room and it's at
least an eight as far as being
good-looking you just got to get the
[ __ ] away from him yeah they're too
good-looking to be spiritual you know
what I mean you've never had to buy a
drink for yourself in your life I don't
give a [ __ ] how much yoga you do yeah
you're not gonna be able to have any
sort of self analysis you know like I
don't think the thought of you know I
maybe I was being a [ __ ] there I don't
think that ever [ __ ] goes through
your head so I got to commend that guy
in Coldplay for not writing a lot of
angry songs he just kind of has like
doesn't just have nice song I think
that's what I think that's the big
problem with that band it's just nice
right these things generally in a good
mood you know the guy seems like a happy
guy that makes you pretty hateable you
don't anybody put on a [ __ ] flannel
jacket right dressed like a lumberjack
you know mocking that hard work as you
go [ __ ] sitting around eating you
goddamn M&Ms in your green room you come
out you said some sing some miserable
song everybody likes you alright
the [ __ ] that guy's name they're
saying all those songs Oh Nirvana right
that cook Cobain man yeah I really wish
he didn't kill himself so I could trash
it more you know
[ __ ] guy I wish I was like you easily
amused thank you [ __ ] know me go [ __ ]
yourself
they [ __ ] thing I'm doing staring at
a dreidel over here all amazed that it
keeps spinning I
well this [ __ ] came out I was like this
guy's at me or is this guy the most
condescending condescending can't ever
he comes out there first [ __ ] video
he's making fun of tap on solos like he
could do it he just didn't feel like
doing it
sorry this these are just the ramblings
of a man who's what who saw the
beginning the middle and the end of hair
metal and he took it all seriously neck
god damn nirvana I just sounded like
Giamatti in that [ __ ] Howard Stern
movie Howard Stern yet goddamn
[ __ ] I mean [ __ ] me DeRosa
rewind that like 15 times you know the
end of the movie went like Pig vomits
career is just completely in the [ __ ]
and he's like standing outside and he's
just dumbfounded at the success that
Howard's had he's just how would start
he just kind of looks away at god damn
[ __ ]
anyways just say you know how about in
2016 you know there's so much so many
real things out there to get your
passion up up about I don't think you
should go around hating Coldplay all
that poor bastard there poor bastard got
married to a beautiful woman that did
yoga oh my god it's over it's [ __ ]
over someone owes self-involved [ __ ]
human beings you're ever gonna find in
your life are gonna be in that [ __ ]
stinky ass yoga room you know speaking
of which I'm probably gonna take a class
this weekend no my wife she stay what's
it man
seven days in she's gonna try to do yoga
this whole [ __ ] month right
and she actually asked me I can't
remember if she asked me on the podcast
but she asked me because you want to go
to one of my yoga classes and I was like
no I was like I'll do yoga but I like
doing it here at the house you don't I
mean where like if I feel like stopping
doing yoga I can just hit pause on the
audio you know
have some cereal and then come back just
immediately fast-forward to the closing
poses right there's nothing wrong with
that
I just hate how when you [ __ ] go in
there they act like they have just the
keys to happiness all the time you know
and there's not one picture of anybody
on the wall you know what these
testimonies going like you know I was a
really miserable [ __ ] and then I went
down and I took [ __ ] Sally Struthers
yoga class here and I don't know she was
just rambling and I was in down dog and
all of a sudden it just clicked and I
have been so happy ever since you know
I'm not saying Yoga is overrated I just
don't need the [ __ ] I don't need the
chatter from the instructor just tell me
the next [ __ ] pose to do it tell me
to breathe okay stop with you with your
goddamn philosophy you ever watch a
cooking show and they just get off on
these [ __ ] tangents it's like what
you just tell me the next ingredient I
don't even know what basil comes from
and how they used to bring it over in
wooden ships I don't give a [ __ ] all
right it comes true actually comes from
basil Romania which is how it got its
name do you know the amount of people
are actually gonna [ __ ] waste their
time tweeting me that there's no such
thing as basil Romania you know as if I
don't know that that city is not in
Italy even somebody did to me the other
day they I talked so much [ __ ] on this
podcast like when people give me [ __ ]
for stuff that I say half the time I
can't remember what they're talking
about so somebody tweeted at me Twitter
at me and said they said you know so I
guess I supported something okay for
whatever reason they took my rambling
seriously and and they said supporting
blah blah blah
he said something do your homework next
time you support blah blah blah right
and then had a link see right right out
of the gate I'm always like who the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] [ __ ]
coming at me with that tote you do your
homework like I work for you you [ __ ]
right so he goes do your
homework and whatever I said about
something his his [ __ ] his homework was
he sent me a link to an article in The
New York Times so that that was his
homework he [ __ ] looked at one
periodical that leans completely one way
politically all right the old liberal
[ __ ] non New York Times so like and
I'm actually I feel like I'm a liberal
right well I would never just read the
New York Times and just be like well
there you go
you know dumb that is that would be like
listening to this podcast and taking it
seriously and wasting the [ __ ] three
minutes you left to tweet me Jesus bill
did you bring it all back around your
[ __ ] old school [ __ ] maybe I did
maybe I did how about von Miller huh you
ever see a more deserving [ __ ] MVP he
just he mugged cam dude he came right in
[ __ ] Cam Newton back to pass give me
that [ __ ] thing right just ripped it
right out of his [ __ ] heads haven't
said that I think I think Cameroon is
that kind of definitely gonna be back
and he's gonna win win a ring and I said
that I tweeted that every right that
default [ __ ] quarterback to [ __ ] on
Cam Newton actually has a [ __ ]
running game he actually has receivers
he actually has a [ __ ] unbelievable
defense and a [ __ ] contemporary coach
Dan Marino had none of those things
he had the receivers do put in Clayton
right other than I'm not gonna go
through this again okay just look up the
[ __ ] look up running backs from 1983
to 1999 during kick during a Dan
Marino's [ __ ] career I told you
Delvin Williams Tony Nathan Kareem
abdul-jabbar the football player he
never he never had his Edwige and James
his Tony Dorsett he never had that man
never had that [ __ ] okay I'm not saying
Cam Newton has that but he has enough of
a [ __ ] team around him whatever keep
talking [ __ ] you wait Cam Newton I'll be
back he needed that as a youngster he
had to feel that [ __ ] awful this is
what it feels like to lose this [ __ ]
game you know
you watched the next time he goes out
there he's gonna [ __ ] I know he's
gonna do bill you don't know what the
[ __ ] he's gonna do you guessed you
guessed and you guessed right right
last year you thought Seattle was gonna
win in the [ __ ] Patriots we know
you've thought your own [ __ ] team was
gonna lose all right let me read a
little bit advertising let me stumble
through some advertising here is I
attempt to read out loud all right with
a [ __ ] out all right
oh this isn't it oh this isn't it oh
here we go all right oh Jesus here it's
that time of year it's that time of year
when you can say get me some
chocolate-covered strawberries cherries
berries everybody oh the stupid [ __ ]
holiday Valentine's Day is just a couple
of days away huh where are you and your
relationship that you're actually
nervous that you have to [ __ ] get you
broad something won't it be nice if you
I'm not gonna read the copy would it be
[ __ ] nice if you could just click on
something and guys yeah [ __ ] you know
you know what Von Miller ripped the ball
out of Cam Newton's hands what if you
just put up box that you could do the
exact opposite the football is far box
of [ __ ] candy right and rather than
ripping it out of her hand you just
place it in there or maybe Sherri's
buries his Cam Newton you go give me
that [ __ ] thing right knee just
frisbee Tovar to your wife girlfriend
there you go huh what'd you get way to
go out of your wake ballot I stays just
a couple of days away everybody is and
there's only one way to win Valentines
to win Jesus cry I resent this copyright
now that I actually have to talk to my
male listeners here like they have to
dance for their women ladies by the way
why don't you get you once you get your
man a box of chocolates in give a
[ __ ] box of chocolates you just give
a little [ __ ] a little picture the
cheek there you go cutie
there's only one sure way to to win on
Valentine's this year and that is to win
her heart all over again with a box of
chocolates Jesus Christ help what is the
reading level of the woman you're with
that all it's going to cost us some
chocolate-covered strawberry tell a
personal story relating to Valentine's
Day well I think it's a complete
[ __ ] holiday all right I resent the
fact that there's some sort of pressure
put on me that I'm supposed to [ __ ]
do something for her because there's no
day that the lady has to do something
for me all right
so [ __ ] you and your strawberries you
have to show some heart to win and
Sherry's berries knows exactly how make
sure to get it right this year with
romantic fresh juicy berries from
Sherry's berries to be honest we this is
really all anybody deserves on a phony
holiday since you just [ __ ] click
click and shoot there you go you know
when she's not looking you eat more than
she does giant freshly dripped
dipped strawberries with Sherry's berry
starting at just 20 bucks
oh hey ago one twenty dollar bill I'll
throw that down over 40% savings and
from my listeners and anybody else where
they advertise in the universe you can
get double the berries for just 10 bucks
just go to berries comm click on the
microphone and type in the code BRR
these strawberries are picked at the
peak of freshness to ensure the best
gift experience yeah I was kidding new
you yank them when they're still green
then they ripen on the truck dipped in
white milk dark chocolaty goodness just
like bananas top with chocolate chips
decorative swivels or nuts delivery is
always guaranteed even on Sunday is the
only way to get these amazing
Valentine's Day d-day deal visit berries
Calm please spell out the word berries
BER RI es comm click on the microphone
in the top right hand corner but the
page type in bur go to berries doc calm
click on the microphone at a code you
might sort it today time is running out
exclamation point
look if you want to get us some [ __ ]
chocolates just get us some chocolates
you know what I mean
[Music]
you know what I've actually waited too
long there's a [ __ ] place in South
Dakota that has like the best [ __ ]
Deadwood that has some of the most
insane [ __ ] chocolates you're ever
going to get you know you could do that
but it's too late now so just remember
that for next year okay guys if you want
to win our heart back ProFlowers
Valentine's Day is this weekend ah here
we go again
only xx day
away I love uh they think I'm gonna do
the math six days away I did it for you
huh tired of guessing wrong what she
wants each Valentine's Day see see
what's in that copy right there oh she
didn't like you got her a gift and what
she didn't like it so then what she
didn't blow you Jesus Christ why does he
just crank one of those music grinders
and you dance around with a little
monkey hat on this guy I don't like any
of this [ __ ]
alright Valentine's Day ProFlowers and
ProFlowers they're here to take the
guesswork out of it yeah I couldn't case
you couldn't figure out getting her
flowers the Valentine's Day trust the
experts at pro flowers who give you the
confidence that Valentine's Day is done
right Pro flowers is offering my
listeners and anybody else in the
universe that dozen red roses plus a
free vase glass vase and chocolates for
just $29.99 oh they're moving in on
Cherie Berry's turf or really do it
right an upgrade to the romantic
long-stem roses with a premium vase
chocolates and a spa kit for night just
night-night just $9.99 sorry go to
proflowers.com and use my code burst I
was just thinking any worse when a woman
tries to be sexy and she isn't she puts
a long stem rose and she tries to do
that Beyonce diva stomp over towards you
you know she looks like she had some
season in physical therapy don't wait
til list we can't send them to her this
week when a co-worker's gush over her
gift you know you did valentine's day
right blow from ProFlowers is quick easy
and delivery for Valentine's Day is
guaranteed Pro flowers are guaranteed
the last seven days and your money back
it's a no-brainer like you give a [ __ ]
after five days can't beat the price
inconvenience ProFlowers takes the care
of the deejay
yeah go to proflowers.com click on the
blue microphone in the top right hand
corner and type in barbie URR that's
proflowers.com click on the microphone
and type in my code ber flowers and
chocolates there you go
shut your goddamn [ __ ] cake hole full
of next goddamn year
alright I'll read the rest of these
later look at my face I got you some
flowers and a box of chocolate and you
won't blow me what the [ __ ] do I do what
the [ __ ] is the rest of my [ __ ] here I
just don't I just don't understand where
it goes
where the [ __ ] does it go it should be
right behind and it always just
disappears this is really an annoying me
oh god is that another [ __ ] celebrity
on the goddamn stump for a political
candidate why did celebrities do that
that just makes me not want to vote for
the person oh look the creator of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is gonna
tell me why I should vote for [ __ ]
that fat guy in New Jersey whatever the
[ __ ] his name is he's got to have an H
in his name like if I was on Wheel of
Fortune I just looked at his name I for
some reason H seems like a fat guy named
you know husky hash fat people eat hash
you know what I mean
you know you know what it's like a
mystery meat and they just [ __ ]
scramble an egg on top of it you know
it's funny I eat hash is that as [ __ ]
is that a sidepiece meal or is that a
[ __ ] side meal whatever the [ __ ] you
call it side dishes hashes side dishes
out of [ __ ] ID I have no idea so many
[ __ ] meals when I was growing up I
found later were side dishes like when I
was growing up mac and cheese was an
entree my mother would just make a big
[ __ ] tray of it and then she'd make
some toasted it was the [ __ ] the Kraft
macaroni and cheese it was frozen right
she did the old right there Fred threw
it the [ __ ] threw it right in the
[ __ ] stove right she made it like
golden brown on top she take it out
scoop it out
your familiar feel [ __ ] out of my face
right a little bit of toast right
buttering the toast the way old-school
moms did every [ __ ] inch of the
goddamn piece of toast that at least you
know at least a quarter stick of [ __ ]
butter on it you know
remember all those [ __ ] meals from
the 70s chicken ala King chipped beef on
toast I've talked about this before
haven't I
green bean casserole was just mushroom
soup and they threw [ __ ] green beans
in it just heated it up I was a [ __ ]
worse man I hated green bean casserole I
always had a strategy that was either
beginning or end any time there was
green I was either getting it out of the
[ __ ] way or I was just gonna put it
off like a term paper I swear to god to
this [ __ ] day man it took me a long
time to ever you eat like mushroom soup
again
you know Paul virzi thinks mushrooms are
useless tell that to the druggies man he
doesn't like mushrooms
he doesn't like corn and he doesn't like
Peas how do you not like Peas man
there's something [ __ ] wrong with you
right you got five you got mashed
potatoes right that I made right okay
and then you take the [ __ ] de spoon
all right and you mush it down and then
you take a big clump of butter even
though you already put butter in you
drop it on there you put salt and pepper
on that and then you got some peas right
next to it the [ __ ] out of here Paul
first you why don't we hang out with
Decker how do you how do you hang out
with somebody that doesn't like Peas
you know god help that bastard if he
ever goes to [ __ ] Scotland you know
then what she pees
anyway Sonny what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about here you know I got my car all
fixed up right I got it all fixed up got
all the dents taken out of it and I
[ __ ] backed into something yesterday
not hard buy something I mean somebody
else's car
[Music]
not hard but hard enough I just put a
couple of hack marks I didn't do what he
think to their car they of course had a
[ __ ] SUV so you know they're like a
dentist or something and it had like
this this [ __ ] license plate holder
thing that just dug right into my bumper
so it's already a little hacked up but
uh I don't know you know it's funny ever
since I the Prius right I used to be
really good at backin up and [ __ ] but
ever since they get like that backup
camera like I I find myself not even
looking anymore
I become worse at it you know what I
mean it's like when you start delegating
power you have a job and just start
delegating power and then all of a
sudden you're just sitting behind your
desk and you like I really have nothing
to do here and then you look up and
there's your superior standing there in
the doorway what are you doing today
you start shuffling some papers and next
thing you know you get laid off right
you just delegated enough [ __ ] power
that's what I've done with that that
backup camera I've delegated so much of
my [ __ ] senses to make sure I don't
run over somebody I really shouldn't say
this is if I ever [ __ ] hit somebody
Oh bad would that be if they played my
own podcast in court right uh Your Honor
we'd like to submit into evidence gbj
the podcast from February the 8th 2016
where he clearly states that the man
does not even look behind his calf when
he backs up Cleo what's the matter it's
a matter buddy
do you know who's here Cleo who's here
who's here Cleo huh you want to eat
somebody you wagging your tail though
you never know
alright buddy relax now that I got you
all amped up huh Nia is there somebody
here yeah
[Music]
you know what's funny about being
married aside from the fact that you got
a whisper on your own podcast sometimes
just to make it day easier it's just the
ups and downs you know I mean you can
see it in your wife's eyes some days she
knows why she marries you married you
and then other day she's like what the
[ __ ] did I hitch my wagon to and I know
it's early I know it's early in the day
but I'm feeling like it's gonna be one
of those what the [ __ ] that I married
day Oh get up here come here get up here
come on how are you buddy huh wait did
you later thank you Jesus
do you do anything easy dude the [ __ ]
thing just collapses down on me we'll do
your homework man all right let's uh
let's read a couple of questions here
for this week was anything else oh I
know I was talking about celebrities
talking about [ __ ] candidates it's
like why the [ __ ] do you think I need
like I'm undecided and then like the guy
who created jag comes on TV or like one
of those stars you know they're always
out there [ __ ] I know what do they do
what are you doing you're an actor
you're a writer the [ __ ] do you know
about running the country shut up stop
ruining the candidate that I like right
I like Bernie Sanders cause he reminds
me of an old [ __ ] club owner that I
had and when you get when he gets mad he
starts screaming and yelling this is
clip of him yelling at Alan Greenspan
when he was running the Federal Reserve
and it's a classic [ __ ] clip put on
the [ __ ] Internet with like Bernie
Sanders takes the [ __ ] you know
whatever the [ __ ] guy from the the
big bank there I just said it Federal
Reserve yeah it takes him to task right
so he's reading the guy the riot act and
it's this amazing clip and right when it
goes for the other guy to respond the
[ __ ] thing ends it's like well I want
to hear what the other guy said why am i
yelling this week I wanna hear what the
other guy says you know what kind of a
[ __ ] dope just watches that clip and
then doesn't try to find
you know what the guy from the Federal
Reserve said right look I should at
least be able to you know point
counterpoint it's kind of like that
country send me that thing look good do
your homework or he just sends me the
thing from the [ __ ] New York Times
I like the New York Times but I would
never just read something that they said
be old well there you go
[ __ ] so I need to know isn't that right
Cleo little exhale into the mic I've
been really doing really good about
keeping my energy low trying to around
the dog to get it to be a little more a
little more mellow your steam try and do
eat the guests um am i torturing you
guys with the [ __ ] thing you know
what that's the only Coldplay song I
know I know there's some other ones I go
see those guys in concert you don't meet
watching some soccer moms losing their
[ __ ] minds huh doing some [ __ ]
dance moves from the [ __ ] what wait a
minute they're actually be younger than
me the hell am I talking about I think I
need to shut the [ __ ] up you know I
think in general I think general bill
Thank You Joey
you might need to shut the [ __ ] up no
I'm actually psyched because I was
trying to write this thing and I just
kept procrastinating all right Cleo I'll
see you
I kept procrastinating I finally just
said [ __ ] it and I just broke it down
into three segments and over the course
of like four days I was able to finish
it and now it's [ __ ] done and it's
like this giant weight off my chest and
I don't have to do [ __ ] today and I'm
all you know what I'm gonna do today I'm
actually bringing my truck over my old
truck I found this this spare tire
assembly you know a lot of them don't
have it at least mine didn't happen I
was able to find it was off this guy's
f250 that he was gonna fix up I just
kept offering him money for he goes now
I don't to get rid of it and I finally
way overpaid for it I got it and they
powder-coated it whatever the [ __ ] that
means to match didn't match my truck and
everything so finally I'm actually gonna
have a spare tire underneath the [ __ ]
thing the way it's supposed to
and like that's my [ __ ] day that's
all I got to do today you know why cuz I
sat down and I got that [ __ ] thing
done
although the door locks at my [ __ ]
house I still haven't done
I bought the [ __ ] premium paint remover
an epoxy remover whatever the [ __ ] that
is I got my little brush I'm gonna try
to get that [ __ ] lock out today
because I told you I got this old-ass
house as I've mentioned a zillion times
and I want the interior door locks to
work because I think it would be [ __ ]
hilarious if when I left one time if I
locked all the [ __ ] doors in the
house and then somebody broke into my
house and every [ __ ] room they had to
like try to break down another door they
just go to turn it it's like [ __ ] man it
still was locked let's go around the
other side
[ __ ] you know ten minutes in they're not
even trying to be quiet and we're like
do what goes in and I just have you know
a bunch of [ __ ] hats and teach free
t-shirts from [ __ ] comedy shows you
know there's such a in intelligence to
just not having really anything of value
in your house you know what I mean I got
a couple of [ __ ] like antique tables
and [ __ ] like that stuff that I kind of
likes but who the [ __ ] gonna steal
that little cat fur glove coming out
with a [ __ ] table on his back you
know they like the [ __ ] they like the
little [ __ ] they come in wearing their
yoga pants right rappelling down from
the [ __ ] roof I just think it would
be hilarious who's getting the ultimate
thing is if you had like security in
your [ __ ] house right and somebody
comes in right and they get to that
certain point I know I've seen this in
movies and they'll all of a sudden
that's just that metal thing comes down
so then they can't leave just brightness
sitting there [ __ ] panicking you know
what I mean
I always thought that that would be
great and then like I was thinking like
eating like a giant room right when
they're in the living room of some [ __ ]
like all of a sudden they can't [ __ ]
get out and they're freaking out then
they just sit in there and they think
worst-case scenario is that the cops are
showing up and they're gonna get [ __ ]
arrested and they're kind of mentally
giving themselves into that and then you
just like you have like a Cobra right
and you just [ __ ] let it in the room
you know generally speaking those things
aren't that fast do you just have it
just just maybe you deep fang the
[ __ ] thing well that's not that's
cruelty to animals right but it's a
reptile if they're not really animals
right no you don't you just let the
[ __ ] thing come in they just show in
the hood
nobody can [ __ ] hiss like a goddamn
reptile man you ever gonna those
alligator farms are you down in Florida
you know I mean and you first of all
you're looking at the people going there
you like dude half of these people have
murdered somebody and fed their victim
to one of these [ __ ] things I mean
just Florida is just especially the
northern part of Florida I mean it just
gets really [ __ ] shady but when you
get those [ __ ] things laid hissing
each other Jesus Christ I mean it just
taps into back I don't get that [ __ ]
that's leftover from when you were a
caveman you know what I mean like just
like I can't even explain that like it
when I went that was what the [ __ ] was I
I can't remember I went to a classic one
to I think was just outside of Tampa no
maybe no so all right at the Rhoden when
Miami or just south it's that one that
has the alligator mouth that you will
walk right into right and I heard that
thing [ __ ] hiss and dude from that
tip in my head to the end of my toe I
took my toes atop my head it [ __ ] it
up
it just went just [ __ ] like I can't
explain the feeling just it that that
feeling when you leaned back in a chair
and you almost fall like my entire body
did that and the thing was way far away
from me and I knew logically that it
couldn't get to me
but I still think that from all those
years of when we just walked around
living in caves that your body's just
still trained that if it hears that
[ __ ] noise that reminds me when I saw
this three toed sloth one time I was in
Costa Rica right and we've taken this
zipline tour it was like the most
northern tip of the [ __ ] rainforest
and the guide you know these [ __ ]
trees were unbelievable was like we were
like it felt like we were 150 feet in
the air and we weren't even mid tree you
looked up it was like another 300 feet
above you it was [ __ ] unbelievable it
was a other than the fact
we were there you know doing his zipline
tour and [ __ ] and had cell phones and
stuff it was a [ __ ] paradise so this
guy did it every day so he knew where
this three toed sloth was and he looked
up and he made this noise of I forget
what the bird is called it's not an
albatross but it does begin with an A
and as a giant wingspan and they're not
even in that area anymore because we
killed all of them
but to this day he imitates in the
second he [ __ ] imitated the thing the
[ __ ] three toed sloth just like got
up and started [ __ ] looking around
and then looked down at us like dude
what the [ __ ]
you know just like dude don't do that
it's not funny right because I guess
those birds are so [ __ ] big that they
would swoop down into the trees and with
their talons they would just [ __ ]
just basically grab these [ __ ]
monkeys and just yank him out of the
tree and you're just completely [ __ ]
Jesus Christ those poor things man what
a [ __ ] way to go you imagine me and
that [ __ ] slow actually I can't
I'm a classic white guy I can't jump
can't [ __ ] run fast none of that [ __ ]
right it doesn't understand dancing by
men anyways then I don't care if you're
good at it
I don't care if you're good at it I just
don't get it it just makes me laugh when
I see a man dancing it just makes me
[ __ ] laugh I'm sorry it's really
immature and I need to grow up when it
comes to that but I'm just being honest
so anyways I just can't imagine being
that [ __ ] thing like his slow and his
[ __ ] awful as I am I just can't
imagine if there was key measures
there's just some giant bird and you
were on it's [ __ ] menu and you lived
outside in [ __ ] trees where birds are
jesus [ __ ] christ the amount of times
you're just sitting there as a
three-toed sloth just chilling talking
to a buddy of yours going like a man
what do you think in the next couple of
days maybe go to that branch over there
and your buddies sitting there talking
to egg be like
oh sorry this [ __ ] thing just grabs
your friend and you think your friend is
just [ __ ] gone just gone
you just seem disappeared whatever
monkeys do and then you're [ __ ]
sitting there like what the [ __ ] right
your heart racing like you just did some
blow but you only got the speed of a
[ __ ] three-toed sloth can you just
sit there with the other 3 toed sloth
doing what just looking at each other
like you know thank God that wasn't me
but what the [ __ ] please make it quick
just [ __ ] see this slice of things
neck already sorry Matt I just had a lot
of empathy when I saw that the way the
[ __ ] it's almost like you had to see
the [ __ ] things face when he made
that noise when he [ __ ] looked around
and looked down and saw that it was us
you should have seen the look on this
[ __ ] thing's face it was just like I
swear to God if it could [ __ ] on us it
would have and you know what we would
have deserved it well at least the guy
who did it would have alright enough
about three toasts lost let me let me
get into [ __ ] reading here why don't
we have to [ __ ] do this type in my
[ __ ] password hey does anybody know
how do I get my computer to [ __ ] link
up with iTunes I actually watched a
video on it the kids going yeah you go
right over here and you click on this
thing and it's like I didn't have that I
must have a different version than him
all right here we go let's get into some
of the reads here or should I just
finished with the advertising let's just
finish the advertise let's get the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of the way first
and then we'll get into some of the
questions for the week all right I
already did a little flowers all right
Oh Dollar Shave Club everybody you know
lots of players will be sporting playoff
beards now that the postseason is here
this should really be done during in
April during hockey season hockey
playoffs the playoffs I leave that to
the pros kick off your year the right
way with a fresh blade shave that's why
millions of other peoples have joined
dollarshaveclub.com Dollar Shave Club
knows the key to getting an amazing
shave is simple use one fresh DSC blade
208 one use a fresh Dollar Shave Club
blade sorry to use dr. cavies easy shave
that's it that's all you got to do
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
razors right to your front door for a
third of the price of those greedy Conti
mega razor corporations that means
listeners who switch now can afford the
luxury of shaving with a fresh blade any
time and save hundreds this year and why
when I was a child and when you combine
that fresh blade with their doctor
copies easy shave butter it just glides
it's unimaginably smooth I'm telling you
it's not your average shave phone all
right it's not gonna drive your skin the
all natural ingredients will leave your
skin feeling soft smooth and moisturized
after every shape take it from me a
[ __ ] [ __ ] who doesn't read use a
fresh Dollar Shave Club blade with dr.
cabbie is easy shave butter if you want
the most gentle shave imaginable join
the dollar shape join
dollarshaveclub.com slash bird today
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash / high
dollarshaveclub.com slash burn and
lastly but certainly certainly not least
lee blue apron all right you need to
know how to cook you don't need to but I
mean you're gonna be in shape if you
learn how to but you don't want to go to
the grocery store you don't have to
[ __ ] deal with all of that [ __ ] right
but you need to know how to cook not
only do you need not only do you feel
like you know your way around the
kitchen
but looking at cooking at home slow down
bill but cooking at home means eating
healthier and saving money instead of
ordering expensive takeout again but
where do you start blue apron has you
covered for less than $10 per meal blue
apron delivers all the fresh ingredients
you need to create home-cooked meals
just follow the easy step-by-step
instructions each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less
no overwhelming trips to the grocery
store can't deal man no more sad takeout
no matter your dietary preferences blue
apron makes it makes it a breeze to
discover and prepare dishes like roast
chicken supreme mashed potatoes gravy
and maple glazed carrots spiced salmon
with black rice avocado and blood orange
salad I didn't know that wasn't such
thing as black rice I know that was
brown rice and white rice right
Caucasian and Latino rice me so horny me
so honey roasted chicken and baby sweet
potatoes with stir-fried Sesame bok choy
I [ __ ] love bok choy but only when I
go to Koreatown every time I try to make
it a [ __ ] it up any Koreans listen out
there Korean Americans Korean Koreans
South Koreans North Koreans huh I would
do that to you in North Korea I wouldn't
do that to you
[ __ ] bosses son there's not like you
have any food right steak sandwich with
caramelized onions garlic aioli and
honey roasted parsnip fries Parmesan and
provolone pizza we got it you got a lot
of [ __ ] tomato quiche
well I supposed to read all of those
delicious and food and good for you
right now you can get your first two
meals for free at blue apron calm / bird
that's blue apron calm / / hey blue
apron calm / / dude that's [ __ ] great
man bring it right to you goddamn Dorf
they show you how to cook it you learn
how to cook a little bit you know you
eat healthy stomach gets flat you know
next thing you know you got somebody to
buy some [ __ ] chocolate strawberries
for alright let's get to the questions
for this week ok trusting water a billy
filter facing I like that one don't
trust drinking water
I don't trust drinking water because my
friends think I'm nuts they always point
to the fact that public drinking water
has tested time and time again
now this Flint Michigan Fiasco it's
surfaced that officials lied about
testing did slow drip tests from faucets
in order to get lower levels of whatever
horseshit shouldn't have been there to
begin with and even wrote it off because
most complaints weren't we're coming
from minorities dude how do you do that
and go to sleep at night how do you do
that how
companies to do that fracking and I'm
not saying I don't know anything about
fracking but you know I've seen that in
some cases it's [ __ ] up the drinking
water how do you not go oh my god we
[ __ ] up what do we do here oh my god
we like Steph act up I'm the worst but
I'm just how do you [ __ ] do it the
best water comes in glass and it's fresh
from a natural spring that doesn't
neighbor a Dow Chemical Plant I stick to
this as much as possible I know I'm not
nuts
I saw a civil action with John Travolta
in the theater once I saw Ellie's of
about 20 years ago and it's hired me
sense what's your level of trust when it
comes to to water and what kind of water
do you drink
thanks for the Thursday podcast love the
music that's Andrew chthamalus go check
go check in on yourself alright I don't
know what is my feelings on it yeah it's
probably a scam or whatever I really
feel that I try to be as healthy as I
can I have this weird thing where you
know I'm trying to be healthy and live
as long as I can while I also feel that
like most people on earth dying would be
a great thing because I just think we're
yeah we were just putting too much
stress on all the fun of natural
resources I believe that personally I do
now have I read enough know do I know
what I'm talking about no it's just what
I do what you guys do I get a little bit
of information and I just run with it in
my brain and then someone reprimands me
on [ __ ] Twitter do your homework man
I actually had an acting gig with one
person one time and they they they
actually got their water delivered and
rather than being in those giant plastic
[ __ ] things he got a tip upside down
they actually were in glass which
anything tastes better in a glass it
always does beer in a bottle tastes
better than beer and it can personally I
feel it does but as far as where they
get the water I don't think it matters
as long as they [ __ ] treat it right
that's it it can't I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know I have no idea I try to
drink water as much as I can when I'm
not [ __ ] boozing but uh no I don't
have any faith in anything anymore I I
don't I went to this little fancy
[ __ ] pet store today to get my dog
some food and they were like are you in
our system and I'm like no I'm not and
they go ok just so you know whenever you
want to be in the system well you get a
5% discount every time and I just want
to be like yeah and what do you get out
of it
what do you get out of it you know you
sell my [ __ ] information to somebody
there was yeah well no we don't well I
know you don't why would you do that why
would you just give me a 5% [ __ ]
discount forever that means you're
either marking the [ __ ] up there's no
[ __ ] way nobody goes out of their way
to [ __ ] make 5 percent less on some
[ __ ] you know forever I could say we're
having a sale you get people in there at
a they kind of get used to going to the
store and then you phase it out you get
5% off every [ __ ] time you know I
think being a paranoid [ __ ] works it
really does except sometimes in
relationships it isn't I say he was just
a guy at the post office I gave him the
barrel all right turn up turn offs hey
Billy buttercups my friend and I were
having a discussion about what turns us
off about girls
the usual gross things and physical
appearance things came up I threw out I
threw out there yeah and I hate it when
girls throw themselves at you with the
disclaimer that if you're if you're
equality if you're equally as into the
girl it's not a problem what do you
think about this is it me or does it
feel weird when a girl just puts it all
out there out there
you said out that out there it starts
casually mentioning her vag because she
thinks it's going to interest you or
something some of my friends thought I
was nuts the other sort of agree thanks
and go crushed yourself it all depends
it all depends on the only person you
know what I mean generally speaking if
you just meet somebody you know and you
have no idea who they are and
just start throwing themselves at you
you know and you look how I look you
like I don't think this is her first
rodeo it makes me nervous that would
make me very nervous as far as like
what's that Beach Boys song she's been
around all over town copulates only
Thursday I would yeah I could see what
that would that would freak you out but
if you know I don't know she's like in
her 30s and she's just like look I'm you
know I'm not looking for a relationship
just want to kind of you know it's gonna
be [ __ ] buddies here yeah yeah whatever
[ __ ] that's what I do too I go yeah
you know that always turns the ladies on
nothing gets them turned on like
cracking your voice yeah
good that you may be completely think
forget what I was gonna say oh [ __ ] I
had a funny story too
god damn it buh-buh-buh-buh oh yeah you
know I I don't like when women try to be
dominant either you don't I mean they
just I don't know they [ __ ] they get
on top and they're like grabbing your
wrists and they got that stupid look on
their face and you just think it like
you know if I wanted to I could just
throw you off the bed not for nothing
but if you're right do it
yeah I understand what you say here if
it's all how they do it if they just
coming up confident their rent to you
yeah but if they just start talking
about their [ __ ] whoo huh yeah a lot
of it is the same it'd be like for a
woman if a guy just came out he just
flops his dick on the bar huh who wants
it
come again
yeah I would think that would turn
anybody off all right global warming
scam all right
global warming scam okay this is like I
some that people keep sending me and
they keep sending it to me as if my
opinion it has any sort of scientific
background I'm just basing it on
scientists
that's all I'm basing it on and that
[ __ ] two and a half times the size of
Texas and two miles deep swirl of
garbage in the [ __ ] Pacific Ocean
then how just about every fish has of
some degree of plastic in their [ __ ]
system okay but even no but none of that
has to do with temperature love you show
it's really refreshing to hear someone
in show business actually talk about
some very important social pertinent
things when the [ __ ] do I ever do that
like what football three-toed sloths
flopping your dick on the bar this these
are important to you I agree with
everything you talk about on your show I
don't need you to he goes except or she
says he or she except global warming the
global warming scam is another system of
control I agree we should stop using oil
and coal these carbon sources are highly
polluting and release toxins and mercury
into the biosphere but this has nothing
to do with global warming I know you
love documentaries God can can you guys
just something about take it in a
country way I know you love
documentaries God knows you don't read
he's probably right look up global
warming swindle on YouTube a little
taste into global warm the global
warming rathole there's a ton of other
information on the web that exposes this
[ __ ] scam good luck and looking
forward to hear what you have to say
about this see I don't get that I'm
supposed to just look up a bunch of [ __ ]
that all agrees with the other side and
then the other side is wrong that's like
me saying to you look up all these [ __ ]
about global warming and how we're
affecting the climate and I'm looking
forward to see what you have to say I
would think that the fact that in France
all the leaders of the world just got
together with all these scientists and
all that and even on the right they've
always been saying it's [ __ ] from
day one from day one they were saying
it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
even they finally came out and they said
yeah it's we are affecting it and then
they were like but it's too late to do
anything now like that's what they came
out with so why would they be doing that
why would they well we'll wait wait wait
you're saying that they're doing it to
try to control us and such a long way to
go isn't it okay they just control us by
scaring the [ __ ] out of us the normal
way like oh there's this group of people
that doesn't have planes or a boat and
they're coming over here to get us like
they've been doing for 15 [ __ ] years
can't they just do that
I'll watch those things but I would like
to know who paid for those who financed
those documentaries because if they're
companies that are getting attacked for
it you know there's obviously you know
getting attacked for the pollutants that
they're putting into the atmosphere and
then you know they could be going well
we need to get this off of us by putting
the real information out there but
generally speaking I is a rule I don't
believe corporations I just don't people
in general I mean I'm full of [ __ ] right
what the [ __ ] would I believe that I'll
watch it you know what I hope you know
what this is thing I actually hope
you're right because then I can have a
lot less guilt and just go out and buy
some [ __ ] goddamn v8 man get out
there [ __ ] drive around do some
donuts PS global warming carbon credits
are controlled by the same crooked
bankers that are [ __ ] up the world
economy well I kind of think like the
bankers don't take control everything
they kind of own everything right
we still make it payments on the white
house do they have to refinance that I
know it burned down in the 1800s who
knows new girlfriend bullied by friends
girlfriend okay so your new chick gets
bullied by who's Franta I guess I gotta
read it alright I wanted your advice on
something minor yet difficult for me to
figure out on how to approach I've just
done pretty well for myself getting a
beautiful girl recently like she's
physically attractive and has an ass I
could balance a beer on good for you
anyway our friend our Frank group is a
pretty good size even though some of our
friends have moved 30 minutes to an hour
away but a problem came up recently a
friend of mine from out of town recently
came by with his girlfriend and after a
night out of drinking my girlfriend
informed me his girlfriend bullied her
and treated her like [ __ ] in high school
all right well it was a long time ago oh
that's the next thing goes I told her
that was a long time ago that's what I
was he goes with 26 now and that she
shouldn't should try to approach her to
which she replied that when the girl in
question said to hello to me she looked
at her and just walked away told her
that was a long time ago wait wait and
that she should approach it
to which my girlfriend implied that when
the girl in question said hello to me
she looked at her and just walked away
wait who walked away that when the girl
in question said hello to me do it I
don't know who's saying what here she
also told me her high school was quite
small and the girl in question and many
others made it hell for her here's my
question for the freckled [ __ ] oh of LA
how would you approach this situation
keep in mind I'm not the best of buds
with the dude we're just in the same
friend circle well what happened you're
26 you're probably gonna see her like
what once every couple of [ __ ] weeks
yeah I don't I don't think it's a
problem I guy I would just look at her
just okay can you stop [ __ ] making a
big deal out of nothing I have a boy
stick your [ __ ] head next you start
bullying her I don't know what I would
do I would just be like yeah I would
just say like you're 26 years old high
school ended eight years ago I just let
it go because she doesn't give a [ __ ]
bullies never remember the [ __ ] that
they did to you and she's probably
jealous because you're beautiful with an
ass you can balance a drink on right
that's probably what it is
I don't know in the meantime why you
take some jujitsu classes alright who
Israeli [ __ ] martial arts I always
want to take that [ __ ] you know little
jujitsu and then that [ __ ] Israel
whatever that Israeli martial arts [ __ ]
is the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] called I don't
know how you [ __ ] know I always just
felt like that [ __ ] is just like you
know because the level the stakes going
on over there like this just there's no
I guess they're all official I don't
know [ __ ] [ __ ] about fighting but I
just felt like that that would be the
[ __ ] you know just because of where
Israel is and how they never have planes
get hijacked or anything they just got
[ __ ] on lockdown you would think that
their martial arts would there would be
there would definitely be a lot of
interesting I would think I couching
just [ __ ] do you take your [ __ ]
index and your middle finger and you
just [ __ ] they probably know how to
do that that macGruber throat snatch
thing you know snatching throats anyways
yeah I don't know what to tell you I'm
not I'm not good at that [ __ ] dude if
you haven't noticed I don't know a lot
about women I really don't like guy I
grew up you know with way too many it
was it was not balanced you don't I mean
it was not it was just [ __ ] I don't
know to this date it's still you know I
had all brothers for the most part and
then the dog even that dog was a [ __ ]
boy you know what I mean it was just
total overload of testosterone and then
my mom and we lived up on a busy street
so we just all interacted with each
other and yeah this is one of those
[ __ ] this is one of those that's one
of those chick moments well I'm just
really bad I'm just like well did she
try to punch you did she have a beat yet
before then like what's the [ __ ]
problem just totally go [ __ ] herself
right you notice too you don't get it
God so frustrating I know I know it's
not you I know it's not you I know
you're trying I appreciate that I could
steal like and they start talking to me
and I sit there and I'm nodding I'm
listening
and just over their shoulder there's a
TV with a game one and I start looking
at it looking at them you know start
acting like I'm rubbing my forehead
you know blocking their view of one of
my eyes so I can look at the [ __ ] TV
I start doing that [ __ ] eventually I get
busted and then they get mad you know
anyways if you would like to donate to
this podcast it's very easy to do it
won't cost you any money
it just cause you an extra couple of
clicks see the index finger you just go
to Bill burr comm and you click on the
podcast page there's a link to Amazon
next time you want to buy something on
Amazon you can do this you just click on
it and I get credit for driving traffic
to Amazon and what if you buy something
they kicked me a couple of bucks or
whatever and and then I used to kick it
to this [ __ ] charity that people sent
me enough [ __ ] that said it was a scam
so now I give it to st. Jude saying you
Jays that's what I try to do I give a
portion of the proceeds
well what portion bill we talking like
an NFL portion no way better than the
NFL I take 10% and I throw it to the
[ __ ] to st. jude's alright that's
pretty good by considering [ __ ] the
NFL does what well they do they like 3%
of that $100 Jersey and then they give
it to the pink lady so she can go out
and get herself a pink Cadillac
alright that's the podcast for this week
everybody once again congratulations to
the Denver Broncos and Peyton Manning
was so [ __ ] great to see that guy go
out a winner man I did not want to see
him you know you know what I mean I
didn't want to see him get [ __ ] anyone
want to see those [ __ ] ass kicked to
get on a Super Bowl I really did not
want to see that and my condolences to
the Panther fans you know you guys had a
hell of a season riverboat ron is that
his name someone's tweeting me says is
that the best [ __ ] nickname in sports
I didn't even know the guys name to be
honest with you but I saw him on the
sidelines at one point the second
quarter and I said to my buddy I go that
guy looks like the winning coach of a
Super Bowl that's what I felt like when
I saw the guy so obviously you guys are
gonna be back a lot of times you get
there and you don't win it the first
time and then you remember what that
feelings like and then you come back and
I don't know you guys should be alright
you'll get one right look at old peyton
manning he [ __ ] hung in there he got
one John Elway came in there this Denver
it's the [ __ ] place to go for old
[ __ ] quarterbacks to get one more
what do you guys think do you think he
retires he should he should there's
already rumors that he's gonna be coming
out here to the Los Angeles Rams you
know which would be very Joe Namath Joe
Willie Joe Willie ended that's actually
that's a good [ __ ] quiz huh
you named Hall of Fame quarterbacks in
teams that they ended with Joe Namath
ended with the Rams
Johnny Johnny Unitas Johnny Unitas ended
with San Diego
I believe it's hard man once you think
once they [ __ ] disappear and they go
off the [ __ ] radar let's pick another
one here Drew Bledsoe who did he finish
with Drew Bledsoe went to the bills then
he went to the Cowboys and I want to say
he went somewhere else Brett Favre where
did he get Vikings who was gonna go to
the Vikings at the end of his career at
the last second said [ __ ] that I'm not
doing it and was a smart move I
mentioned him earlier Dan Marino Dan
Marino had an offer and he said no
[ __ ] I'm not doing it and what's
great is all of his highlights he's
wearing the Dolphins uniform he doesn't
have that sad you know the last team I
[ __ ] played for uniform Emmitt Smith
what did he finish huh Arizona Franco
Harris Seattle Seahawks you know what I
think I invented a good drinking game
might you just go through then
somebody's got to look it up and that
means somebody knows all the answers you
know what I think I just thought I had a
great idea but I didn't all right go
[ __ ] yourselves out check it out yeah on
Thursday